this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer now that you finished the
mandalorian on Disney Plus given up on
Artemis Fowl after ten minutes and puts
animation on in the background while you
texts it's time to squeeze the last bit
of value out of your 7 bucks a month by
revisiting the low-budget spin-off of a
syndicated Disney Afternoon show that
clocks in under 80 minutes with credits
it is one of the best films of an
otherwise soft era for the Big D sorry
dinosaur at least you only cost Wow 127
million in 20 years ago money alrighty
then a goofy movie welcome to the world
of goofy where the finish are finished
the birds are birds and everyone else is
somewhere on the spectrum between dog
cat and man where you'll see slapstick
legend goofy like you've never seen
before a suburban dad desperately trying
to connect with the son who hates it
what the heck you trying to do trying to
get away from you what kind of fucked-up
kids movie is this every teenager thinks
their parents are the most embarrassing
people in the world but only cookie son
max can make a solid case for it
he's up to ditch his dad and get with
Roxanne a girl he's never spoken to she
finally says hi Lea but puts on a
pedestal and is so thirsty for he
literally sees her in the water
can't blame him the mid-nineties were a
goal nature animated love interests
together this goop troupe will set off
on a road trip across a post-apocalyptic
mirror dimension that's geographically
identical to our own and bond as they
narrowly avoid committing vehicular
homicide
[Music]
q/a my and rescue Max's best friend from
his abusive dad if my dad catches me
with this he'll kill me if my dad finds
out it's gonna nuke my entire existence
dad is gonna smash me like a bug Oh in a
film that teaches us the importance of
clear and honest father-son
communication but since it has the same
screenwriter as Al and it also teaches
us how lying to girls just makes them
like you more I really am a prince my
dad no no snows power line Oh shucks off
so buckle up for the Disney adventure
with the biggest heart and the lowest
stakes we're instead of rescuing a
kingdom or breaking an ancient curse the
hero must endure spending time with an
actually alive parent speaking of which
where is Max's mom anyway full of
amazing songs from Tevin Campbell s
power line
skippable songs from goofy do you long
to shed your weary low and the exact
amount of polish or before it gets
obnoxious look it's the Leaning Tower of
Pisa that's it stop right there perfect
not a second more story the dog father
Lil Bow Wow
whittany who Nemorino wait his name is
PJ Pete Pete jr. Pete and his dad is
Pete Pete how did their civilization
last this long Kelly Kapowski skipping
school and conceivable cheese the Jews
and all dogs flow to Tevin Mad Max furry
road trip
so are we gonna talk about how they're
being followed by nuns everywhere they
go hey you guys were waymarsh on my
movie I don't even know why PG and Bobby
you like these videos I am a goofy
goober you're a goofy goober we're all
goofy goobers yep Tostitos Doritos
Fritos Cheetos they're all Ito's get
crazy with the Cheez Whiz mi see Kate UI
mo u se